alors je connais depuis je présentais ça
tu l'a connue avant moi sûrement alors
tu viens en fait ce qu'on sait pas c'est
que tu viens de la petite bourgeoisie du
nord et que quand tu étais petit chez
toi au dessus de chaque lit avait un
crucifix toute assez et mon père en
plaisantant me disait toujours que
j'allais bonne soeur tu vois comme un
jour ma joie alors tu as écrit dans son
livre moi la scandaleuse que tu avais
découvert la jouissance en faisant du
vélo c'est vrai ça comment ça s'est
passé raconte quoi complètement par
hasard de reproduire la chose tu dis que
les actrices de x qui disent que cela
leur fait rien c'est de l'intox et que
quand on fait ce métier on peut pas
faire semblant finalement c'est vrai nom
mais je crois je crois que bon on peut
faire semblant mais les actrices pour
marquer ce cinéma là sont forcément des
actrices qui avait conquis avec la
sensualité et l'érotisme
sinon public n'adhère pas à toi ça te
plaisais comme un prix bien sûr tu te
cache pas les même sexe mais je ne m'en
cache chez toujours pas alors tu l'aimé
tellement le sexe qu'après le boulot est
arrivé quand même de faire des heures
sup est arrivé de participer le soir à
des partouzes ouais mais ça c'est mon
côté simon côtier très entier et je
décide de faire quelque chose je le fais
à fond et j'ai eu envie de
de connaître le sexe j'ai été au bout du
bout des choses dont tu dis qu'un jour
dans une partouze tu as vu une vedette
de la chanson du cinéma suicide pas tu
ne vas pas le citer une fille qui s'est
fait sauter par son mec 99 c'est
beaucoup quand même temps c'est lewis et
beaucoup oui ça dure et qu'en même temps
un certain temps comme le temps que met
le canon pour se refroidir
tu raconte aussi comment ta carrière
avant de faire cette carrière dans le
sind x tu croyais que tous les sexes
était pareil qu'ils avaient la même
taille le même calibre
ai-je été aperçue après qu évidemment
c'était pas du tout c'est marrant parce
que c'est vraiment une obsession
complètement masculine avec quelques
monsieur moi je vois sur surmonter la
question qui revient le plus j'ai un
sexe de temps de centimètres comment je
fais je suis comme celle de cami del
36,15 cogiter à 36,4 là est absolument
pas bon non ce qu'on va faire après
l'émission et c'est une des questions
que les hommes posent le plus c'est
vraiment qu'est ce qu'il disait le
raconte
mais justement la question qui pose le
plus c'est jagex de ce et cm d'ici 2015
serait caisse comment je fais que tu
grandis quoi mais j'ai dit à 13 par une
jambe du dit quoi mais l'importance de
la chaussure à sa taille
ouais la taille c'est pas important
certains anciens attention faut pas non
plus dire n'importe quoi c'est important
mais c'est pas la chose essentielle
la chose essentielle c'est qu'il soit
dure déjà à on l'applaudît logique
[Applaudissements]
alors justement le plus gros prix jamais
vus disais combien que j'ai bien entendu
parler celui que tu as vu alive 35
bon ben voila je suis désolé de le dire
c'était pas un âne
c'était pas là tu croyais aussi toujours
dans son livre je vais pas inventer que
tous les sperme avait le même goût oui
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai aussi c'est
des choses comme ça mais tu t'aperçois
qui avaient des salles et des sucres et
des piscines
moi je suis piste à cheveux
c'est vrai que les ardeurs la haine
types qui font les films x là c'est vrai
qu'ils sont tellement habitués à se
retenir quoi parce que ça dure longtemps
les prises et c'est ce qu'elle veut dire
c'est vrai qu'après une piste mastur
pour qu'on voie ce qu'on appelle leur
accord et jacques quoi qu'on voit
vraiment le sperme qui qui coule c'est
vrai qu'à force de se retenir
il peut plus jouir autrement qu'en se
masturbant c'est pas vrai non je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
qu'ils sont 10 agirait comme comme dans
tout vrai et les filles qui sont ce qui
se pense aux dominés dans les films x
elles sont considérées un peu comme les
cascadeurs dans le cinéma
normal c'est vrai tu vas tu sais ce que
je dis aux mid est mon livre il été bon
maintenant c'est une façon de miser sont
plus considérés comme des cascades de
paris caméras sur les je crois je crois
que non c'est non c'est à dire que comme
moi je ne faisais pas ça on vous appelle
à quelqu'un pour me doubler
je vivais des marques certains comédiens
qu'ils font pas toutes leurs cascades
ah oui c'est ça il y avait des rats
corsair que toi tu disais qu'après on a
mis d'accord et des filles dont celle où
elles font que ça j'arrive le matin
viennent pour ça donc c'est intéressant
on apprend des trucs alors tu as tourné
les scènes de l'aide via nice mme toi
oui j'ai absolument gagner mais ça c'est
un d'entre eux c'est pas ton truc
potenti clitoridienne quand même mais
alors il ya des enfants ça très bien
le sado masochistes a essayé pas du tout
c'est une des choses ce qui moi ne
m'attire pas du tout parce que d'abord
j'ai horreur de souffrir je n'aime pas
faire mal alors je vois pas très bien où
je vois ma place et la zoophilie pas du
tout pourtant dieu sait si j'aime les
animaux mais
passez pas par contre je condamne pas du
tout et je veux dire j'ai vu des gens le
faire oui j'ai vu déjà en fort mais je
condamne pas du tout parce qu'après tout
l'animal a l'air d'aimer ça
quels types d'animaux des chiens les
chiens surtout des chiens oui écoute
chez fayard paris qu'un journal the au
fil en france maintenant tu vas garder
on va voir ça on y apprend t-on petit
téléviseur regarde